so in
mythology the giant is often the symol
for the
state and in Norse mythology the first
giant is called
eir uh eir he created many more Giants
and he was eventually slain by the god
Odin and from his body they created the
new
world now I think there's a lesson from
that story for for all of us here at the
network State conference and that is
that we can build the New Order using
the pieces from the old and that's what
I'm here to talk to you about
today uh my name is sandre Raj I started
my career as a policy adviser to the
government of
Norway I grew frustrated with the pace
of change that we had in government uh
So eventually I left that job to become
a digital Nomad and start a
startup uh when I did that I also lost
one of the good things we have in Norway
which is that we have a great social
safety
net uh since my the company I was
running was a freelancer platform I also
realized that this is a problem that
many other people who work online have
so therefore I set out to build its
replacement why so essentially the
internet has made everything
geographically borderless and I don't
have to tell you that but our social
infrastructure and institutions is built
for a world where that is not the case
so for this reason the citizenship
infrastructure that it provides that the
uh Legacy countries provide is becoming
increasingly
obsolete so what's the solution the
solution is to build a new country on
the internet where the infrastructure
that it provides is global and
digital
so we are essentially working on making
a digital citizenship that each of you
in this room can get as a second
citizenship that includes both a global
social safety net and a
passport in the future I predict that
more PE a lot of people will view
countries more like products than they
do
today our progress so far has been
amazing we now have almost 30,000 paying
members and over $25 million in yearly
revenues this has given us great
capabilities to pursue our mission with
even more
strength so how are we getting there
well there's essentially two tracks that
we are pursuing in parallel one is the
social safety net and the other is the
passport our goal is to eventually offer
them as as a package as a citizenship as
a service as it says here on the
slide I think that this will be one of
the core infrastructure that is useful
for the network State ecosystem uh in
fact our plug-and-play health insurance
and social safety net products is
already used by several other network
State projects uh like prospera that
spoke here
earlier so step one uh of our mission
was to build the global social safety
why why would an internet country have a
global social safety net well think of
it this way the
majority of the budget for all countries
in the world is the social safety net
today so observing this fact plus the
observation that it becomes obsolete for
digital
Nomads uh that led us to conclude that
this is a central task uh that we want
our internet country to
provide and this essentially means the
the social protections that you would
conventionally get through a nation
state like health insurance income
protection retirement and the like
provided to you as a digital
subscription that you can use
worldwide step two is to launch the
plumia passport a truly Next Generation
Global
passport a brief story of how we landed
on the strategy that we have to make
this passport it starts web Summit in
2019 where we gave a talk where we
predicted the rise of nomad visas as
countries would start to compete to
attract digital Nomad
citizens and in that audience of that
talk said a guy from
Barbados 6 months later coid hit and
that man then sent a letter to his
government proposing Nomad visas as a
way to save Barbados a struggling
tourist dependent
economy they implemented that in just
two
months now since that time in the
following 3 years 80 countries have
implemented Nomad
visas and we were even invited to the
United Nations to talk about this idea
to the countries of the
world so just to explain Nomad visas are
multi-year visas that you can get just
with an income requirement and it's made
specifically for digital
Nomads so it is on this success that we
are charting a path for like a super
passport that will actually
work uh we will soon release the MVP uh
which is called The Nomad border pass so
think of it as shenen if you're familiar
with the EU shenen but for countries
that have NAD
Visas so by making this we are also
building diplomatic relationships with
countries with nation state countries
around the world ensuring that our
passport will be accepted at at Borders
worldwide by the end we will have all
countries in the world
participating allowing for a passport
that truly makes you a global
citizen so how will the world change if
we
succeed uh so think back to the 1600s
when the nation state first appeared it
wasn't that the city states which was
the previous Paradigm disappeared
overnight rather there was a transition
period where the tasks and
responsibilities were reallocated
between the city and the
nation I think that this transition is
an analogous to what will happen in the
transition that we have ahead of us some
activities and infrastructure that used
to be the purview of the nation state
will move upwards to the global layer
where it can be more efficiently
provided
for why start with digital Nomads for an
internet country so we started with
digital nomads ads one because by
definition they are early adopters
willing to try a new internet country
but two what has happened over the last
years is that digital Nomads as a
constituency have moved from The Fringe
Of The Fringe to being slightly more
mainstream today there are almost 17
million
Americans who say that they are digital
Nomads 72 million who say they want to
become a digital Nomad over the next 3
years so if you only take those the
American Nomads and say that's their own
country that would be in the top 20 most
populous countries in the world and the
figures are similar for Europe and
they're Rising fast
worldwide digital Nomads is not a fringe
movement anymore it is already a large
enough constituency that we can build
our internet country for
them I founded this company in 2018 with
my friends Hans and Sarah today we have
over 150 people from more than 60
countries working full-time to realize
this
Vision we did w comit in 2018 and we
have raised over $50 million in VC
funding so
far our work aims to level the global
playing field essentially from between
citizens of different countries ensuring
equal opportunities and ultimately we
believe freedom for
everyone within the network State
ecosystem though
I think that our strategic Niche is
precisely that we are friendly with the
existing
order we see ourselves as the bridge
Builders between the nation states of
old and the New Order that is emerging
on the internet and here
today I do in fact believe it is crucial
that nation states get into a positive
sum competitive Dynamic where each of
them try to succeed rather than be
motivated by fear because then they will
try to ban
everything so I invite you to join us uh
already today you can go get on the wait
list for The Nomad border pass a 5-year
visa to 10 countries that's our
MVP uh you will also get our newsletter
you know the meetups to have for and
many people dedicated to the cause of
bringing about this
country Dave Cook an anthropologist at
University College London he said in
this
article uh that magazine wrote about
plumia he said he had heard talk about
digital Nomad Nations before but it was
usually on a beach somewhere when
someone's been smoking a bit too
much I actually appreciate this
sentiment because it shows how far we've
come already the reality is that we are
closer than
ever next year we will launch the full
social safety net and The Nomad border
pass the dream of an Internet country
will soon be realized in fact I am
certain that my son uh who was born last
week by the way uh will grow up as a
citizen thank
you and when we look back to today 100
years from now I am confident that this
will be one of the major social
transformations of Our Generation so
thank you very much for listening I'm
SRE Raj come find me after thank
you